thank you for having me I am proud of
Roxburgh car and
a PhD candidate over in the Stanford
machine learning group and today I
thought I'd share three opportunities
for AI for to improve medical diagnostic
testing and walk you through three
research examples from the Stanford
machine learning group as case studies
of these the traditional model of
clinical practice today can be thought
about as three different steps diagnosis
prognosis and treatment in diagnosis
we're concerned about asking what
happened to the patient in prognosis
were concerned about predicting what
will happen to the patient and in
treatment the doctor is concerned about
deciding what action to take with AI
applications we will see all three of
these steps being transformed over time
so imagine a world in which a machine is
responsible for interpretation of
medical images for diagnosis prediction
of mortality from electronic health
record and prediction of a treatment
that's specific to an individual rather
than a treatment that is common for all
people and AI has been making progress
on all three of these areas today we'll
focus on techno sious which concerns
with providing an explanation for a
patient's health problem and of course
this particular decision inform
subsequent healthcare decisions the
diagnostic procedure begins when a
patient experiences a healthcare problem
at some point they might decide to
engage with the healthcare system go to
their doctor at which point the main
bulk of the diagnostic process begins
and this can be summarized as doctors
and other healthcare stakeholders using
information gathering to update their
working diagnosis for the patient or
during tests a updating diagnosis test B
updating diagnoses and this is
communicated to the patient at which
point treatment can begin and of course
this loops back into getting more
information to update the working
diagnosis for the patient let's imagine
a world with AI in which this diagnostic
process might look a little different
rather than a patient experiencing a
healthcare problem before they engage
with the system can we have AI provide
alerts even before a problem is
experienced rather than having a patient
decide that they want to call their
doctor or even bothered a doctor with
something that might not be totally
wrong with them how about have a mobile
diagnostic Asian to communicate with the
patient the information gathering step
could be tailored to particular patients
using their history using their genetic
profile rather than ordering the same
set of diagnostic tests for every person
communication of diagnosis is one place
where health care often fails but what
if we had diagnostic assistance take the
place of that coordination and
communication within doctors and between
the patient their family and their
doctors as well
finally on treatment one big problem is
adherence to medication can we have AI
make an impact there let's focus on the
information gathering step itself
because this is a major source of
diagnostic error right now if you ask a
doctor to boil down this process it
would divide into four different aspects
the first which is taking a clinical
history and interview performing a
physical exam second sending a patient
for referrals or consultations and then
the last one of obtaining diagnostic
testing and this is a complex part
itself which involves deciding what
tests the right tests to order and after
ordering that tests to interpret it
let's focus on that one
over the past hundred years diagnostic
testing has become a critical feature of
standard medical practice mammograms of
the breasts are a common diagnostic test
so are ECGs of the heart diagnostic
testing can be broadly categorized into
two categories pathology and radiology
pathology further breaks down into lab
medicine and anatomic pathology let's
take an example of each so a lab
medicine will deal with testing of fluid
specimens such as blood and urine while
anatomic pathology is dealing with
testing of solid specimens such as
tissues and cells radiology allows us to
look into the human body look at
sections of the human body through
imaging technologies like x-rays
ultrasound CT SMRs and more recently PET
scans what do we imagine this world will
look like with AI some examples of
things that are already going on in lab
medicine deep learning is being used to
classify white blood cells from
microscope images we can use AI to
automatically detect if a cancer has
metastasized to the lymph nodes we can
look at chest x-rays and automatically
decide what pathologies to that chest
x-ray or set of chest x-rays have with
AI there's another part of the
diagnostic testing world that's being
more and more enabled and this is mobile
health and with mobile health the idea
is to be able to continuously monitor
health in a way that hasn't been
accessible to doctors just because of
the amount of data and the frequency
with which it is generated so one
question that you might have in your
mind right now is what's new about AI
why haven't we solved these problems in
the last 10 years or 20 years why is now
the right time so the traditional
machine learning framework can be
divided into two parts there is training
and there's prediction and in training
the usual setup is there's some labeled
data X&Y and a machine learning
algorithm is used to learn the mapping
from X to Y then come prediction or
testing time there's data that doesn't
have any labels going into a machine
learning algorithm that is trained which
is used to generate a prediction great
traditionally this has looked like the
following setup there's an input it
could be an image of a car and then
there's a person responsible for feature
extraction what do I mean by feature
extraction let's say I wanted to learn
to recognize a particular type of
medical image I might go to a doctor and
say hey how do you recognize this
particular pathology they might say hey
edge detection is important so I might
design a filter on top of the images
which makes the edges more prominent
might extract those then feed that into
machine learning classifier which can
ultimately use that processed extracted
features to get to the outcome and this
has been the traditional regime of
machine learning for a long time the
bottleneck here has been the person
sitting on the chair the bottleneck is
human time and creativity that goes into
that feature extraction step but what's
happened over the last seven years is
that deep learning methods have been
able to eliminate the feature extraction
step by saying here's an input which
might be an image it might be an audio
signal and we can go straight to the
output without having this extra feature
engineering step and this change has
been enabled by lots of data by loss of
computation and a few algorithmic tweaks
to old algorithms that weren't working
that well when we didn't have that much
computation and that much big data one
question I get asked a lot is well
what's the next paradigm shift that's
about to occur in deep learning a lot of
what ml engineers do is still make a lot
of engineering decisions of how to
design how to feature engineer
these neural networks now so rather than
feature engineering of data it's now
moved into network engineering a lot of
decisions are about how to how many
layers to have in a network how to go
about choosing the right optimization
algorithm for training the network how
to choose data augmentation
methodologies and all of these are still
decided manually and often through
heuristics which may or may not be that
good
and the trend increasingly in deep
learning has been to automate that a way
to make all those decisions automatic
rather than having people decide
engineers decide what those should be
have data decide make those decisions so
now that we've seen the paradigm shift
that AI is brought about what are some
opportunities that AI has in medical
diagnostic testing right now the first
opportunity that I'm going to talk about
is in continuous monitoring of health
let's take arrhythmias for example so
arrhythmias refer to an irregular
beating of the heart and it is a
condition that affects up to 3 million
people in the US every year and affects
a lot more worldwide one of the most
common arrhythmias is atrial
fibrillation which alone affects 33
million people in the world and costs a
lot of money to treat arrhythmia
detection has come to the forefront of
public attention with devices like the
Apple watch which are able to now
automatically monitor whether a patient
has atrial fibrillation in their heart
rhythm there's evidence to suggest that
continuous monitoring of a patient's
health including their heart rhythm
would reduce the morbidity and mortality
associated with heart disease and paired
with automated real-time detection this
would have big societal benefits and big
health benefits in terms of being able
to save lives we did some work in the
lab that I'm about to share with you on
detecting arrhythmias
from amber
turi ECGs so traditionally the ECG test
shows the electrical activity of our
time has been done in hospitals and the
way it's set up is lots of electrodes
are attached to different parts of the
body and over a few minutes the
electrical activity of the heart is
recorded but it turns out that catching
the rythme 'as for a few minutes is
often insufficient what is often
required is tracking of the patient's
heart activity for a long duration and
so Holter monitors came about and are
prescribed by cardiologists who tell
their patients go home where this device
for 24 to 48 hours and let's find out
what might be going on
more recent devices have gotten smaller
and now to the extent of just being a
patch on the chest which can monitor for
up to two weeks and a patient can press
a button if they feel a symptom let's
look at the difference in the amount of
data this generates the heart beats
about 1.6 million times in 14 days this
is a lot for a cardiologist to actually
manually go through and this is a real
call for being able to do ECG
interpretation automatically to figure
out what's going on but of course is
that question sorry so you say treadmill
tests yeah yeah so there are there so
the question was so ECGs are also used
for treadmill tests do we do any of that
right now not in this particular study
here we were looking at ambulatory ECGs
which were prescribed to patients by
cardiologists who are wearing this this
particular patch so in this particular
case there is no stress test
although these patients could have been
doing any activity while their activity
was being monitored
thank you and all right
identify delicious you can spin great
okay so if I can recap your point there
are many available devices right now
that are able to do automated ECG
interpretation can we not do that
already what was what was the study
ashlynn knew or what was going on there
so it turns out and hopefully I will
convince you of that by the end of the
section that this is actually a very
hard task to be able to distinguish
between various types of arrhythmias and
we have some numbers on how well
cardiologists perform in two tasks as
well yeah so the first challenge in
automated to CCG interpretation is the
amount of signal that we're dealing with
consider the difference between a
12-lead ECG and a single lead ECG so 12
lead ECG is the traditional system which
is done in the hospital bed where you
can see there are several electrodes
attached on the left and on the right is
what is called single lead ECG which
generates one signal now you can think
about having multi
pull leads versus having single leads as
having multiple perspectives into the 3d
electrical activity of the heart while a
single lead ECG only gives one of those
perspectives into the hearts electrical
activity the second challenge is that
the differences between heart rhythms
are often subtle the ECG consists of
repeating cardiac cycles and each rhythm
is identified by looking at features
within a cycle and between cycles so
within a cycle there's the P wave which
roughly corresponds to the atrial
electrical activity the atrial
contraction and then there's the QRS
wave which roughly corresponds to the
ventricular electrical attraction and
there is the recovery phase which is
represented by a T wave and here's what
the normal sinus rhythm looks like it's
defined by characteristics like having
60 to 100 beats per minute having a P
wave the small one before every QRS wave
and having a narrow QRS wave and these
sorry s the elevated myocardial
infraction yeah no that's that's great
I'm glad I'm glad you caught that I
might have copied the wrong picture but
I'm not a I'm not a cardiologist but my
model is so maybe I'll pass it into my
model later and figure figure your
confirmation the second type of rhythm
is an ectopic atrial rhythm and the way
this is distinguished is that there is a
different P wave and ei R and sinus
rhythm are the two most confused rhythms
and they're they're very easy to confuse
because they have a very similar
morphology except for the P wave the
third challenge is that different
rhythms have different levels of
seriousness so confusing between ei R
and sinus is not clinically meaningful
because ei R is a benign arrhythmia but
if the rate if the heart rate was
higher than hundred beats per minute
then it's not ei R it's super
ventricular tachycardia which unlike ei
R is treated by doctors and
cardiologists when we started off this
project and looked at what people had
done in the past to do automated ECG
analysis we saw that the bulk of the
work was focused on feature engineering
approaches and this included figuring
out the right discrete wavelet
transforms the continuous wavelet
transforms but each of these were very
rhythm specific you wanted to know what
rhythm you wanted to identify a priori
and for a different rhythm type you
would have a different set of parameters
with a different mother wavelet that
would help you identify that particular
rhythm and then there was a lot of
pre-processing that went into it
including bandpass filters but these one
has to engineer the right thresholds and
then there's a bunch of domain knowledge
that went in like looking at the
interval between the two our Peaks or
the amplitude of the our peak itself we
took a different approach we said let's
take the raw ECG signal and a raw list
of rhythms that that ECG signal has such
that each rhythm corresponds to an equal
section of the input ECG signal and then
use a neural network to do the sequence
to sequence tasks to map from X to Y so
we use a 1d convolutional neural network
where the convolution is over the time
dimension of the input and then we have
a 34 layer deep network now a neural
network is a function and the more the
layers there are the richer the function
is and the richer the function is the
better it should be able to fit to the
training data however when people were
going deeper with neural networks they
were finding out that the deeper
networks were actually having a larger
training error than the smaller networks
but this shouldn't be the case because
the deeper networks should have a richer
solution space so they found out that
this was because the optimization of the
deep network was poor one of the ways
that it was proposed to solve this
problem was to say ok we will at these
short cut paths in the network and what
these short cut paths will do is they
will reduce the number of hops it takes
for the error to propagate from the last
layer to the first layer so the now the
function we want to learn changes
slightly where if the original function
that we wanted to learn was f of X now
we're learning f of X excuse me if it
was H of X we're now learning H of X
minus X so the structure of the neural
network changes a little bit but there
are no extra parameters an extension of
the work figured out that the fewer the
operations on the path of the shortcut
connection the better the network
optimizes so on the left you can see
there is a Rayleigh non-linearity while
on the right the only operation that
takes place is the addition operation
and that one performs better because
there are fewer things in path in in the
path of the shortcut another idea that
came about was the use of drop up within
these which the dual blocks to make
these networks generalize more the way
to describe dropout is it's like if
you're a Marvel fan it's like the Panos
of neural networks where half of the
neurons within a layer are dropped and
one interpretation of this is that you
can think of it as an ensemble of
different models
so we collected data from patients
wearing this geo patch that would have
been continuously monitoring their their
their heart activity and we got this
from about 29,000 patients we got 64,000
ECG records of a total of 32,000 minutes
and this was 600 times bigger than the
previous data set that had been used for
in Mia detection which is the MIT BiH
data set and for each of these sequences
we had ground truth annotation provided
by a clinical ECG expert who decided
here's where rhythm a ends and starts
and here's where rhythm B ends and
starts etc etc and then we collected a
test set and in this test set what we
did was we had a committee of
cardiologists decide okay what is the
ground truth that we're going going to
go for and this was set by the committee
and then we took a separate set of
cardiologists and we put them in
individual rooms and then measured their
performance by having them annotate the
test set as well so now we can have a
comparison of how well cardiologists do
and how well the model does so how close
do we get to experts so here is the
results displayed on an ROC curve so the
ideal point to be on this graph is the
top left corner where the y-axis is
sensitivity which is how many how many
of the patients that have a particular
condition do I catch and then there's
one minus specificity which deals with
those who do not have the condition and
the top left corner is ideal and you can
see that the model is a curve and that
curve is generated by looking at
different thresholds of the model so I
decide any one over 0.1 probability
decided by the model is considered to be
a positive prediction and all the way
from 0.01 to 0.99 and that's how that
curve is generated and what we're
looking to find is whether the
cardiologist points which are the red
and the green point which is the average
lies lies below into the right or above
and to the left or below and to the
right means that the model is at least
as good if not better than the
cardiologists which seems to be the case
in three of these examples that I've
drawn the first one is atrial
fibrillation which is that one of the
most common serious arrhythmias here so
[Music]
that's C so we are measuring both of
them so sensitivity would be along the
axis of that would include true
positives and it would include false
negatives and then the specificity would
include true negatives and false
positives
yeah so that's a great question
we don't we could we could make a guess
that three cardiologists and a committee
would be better than one but really
there's there's there's no way from this
to tell to tell whether there was a
single cardiologist who would have been
the absolute gold standard
what is increasingly being done in this
is to figure out using a using a richer
diagnostic test to set the ground truth
and then having the test being done on a
less a less rich diagnostic test like
like ECG interpretation but in this case
it's really the committee that's
deciding but one point I think would be
is interesting here is assuming the
error rate reduces as one goes from one
cardiologist to cardiologist to three
cardiologists and I think it can be
shown statistically that it's sort of
how probable it is that the model it
performs as well as several of these
experts making some assumptions about
the data were there other models is 3 of
12 or 3 or 30 or 350 so these three
examples are three classes three types
of arrhythmias and I'll show you on one
of the future slides how the performance
was across all of them that's great
that's a great questions how much time
has given to the doctors and to the
algorithm so to the doctors they were
not given a time limit they were just
asked to has to make the annotations
until until they completed the test set
for the algorithm how long it took to
generate predictions for all of these
was within a minute so how do how do I
know that the left-hand corner is
actually true the doctors looks at it
and say it's not sure yeah so if if the
model is outperforming each individual
how can we even measure that with with
sort of high confidence how do we know
that's correct
so here the ground truth is set by a
committee that's able to discuss things
with each other in case they have
disagreements so we're assuming the
ground truth provided by a committee of
cardiologists against which each of
these individuals is being measured is
going to be more correct than any
individual cardiologist so it's just an
assumption that we make that this is how
well you know a this is sort of and and
I think one of the other ways of
measuring the ceiling of this would be
to have two different committees and
measuring the agreement between two
different committees and that would
provide a sort of sort of Bayes error
for for the top left great when we
looked at where the mistakes were made
on a confusion matrix here's the model
on the left side and the expert on the
right side and by experts this is this
takes the average over all of them see
that one of the most common diagonal
points is that is the difference between
a AR and the sinus rhythm which we saw
earlier was a source of confusion but
one that isn't clinically meaningful
here's another one that's interesting so
there are two rhythms there is IV R and
V T and one of them has benign and the
other is dangerous and one of the
differences between the model confusion
matrix and the expert confusion matrix
is that the model makes less of a
mistake of calling something benign when
it actually can be dangerous here's the
performance of the algorithm and the
cardiologists as measured by the f1 on
on all of the different rhythms that we
were looking at another advantage of the
model here in terms of its performance
was that on different types of hard
blocks it was able to get a good score
and also on the most common serious
arrhythmia which is atrial fibrillation
so the first opportunity we talked about
for AI to improve medical diagnosis was
in continuous monitoring of health the
second one is in reducing medical error
so in 1999 a report came out by the
Institute of Medicine that estimated
that 44,000 to ninety-eight thousand
people died in US hospitals as a result
of preventable errors question
say the outcome of the previous session
yeah so yeah so that's a good question
what was the what was the reception from
doctors of this particular of this
particular experiment I think in general
the way doctors feel about these
automated ECG interpretations that there
been a lot of studies about these is
that they're just not accurate enough
and they're good for some of the things
but really need a manual review to go
through and say okay this is exactly
what's going on and this study and there
there are a few others like these now
that look maybe particularly at atrial
fibrillation had had more of a sense of
okay this could be done automatically
now I think more of a reception was
given to Apple's EKG released to the
general public because that's something
which is already in use by real patients
as opposed to something which is done in
a control lab setting where it's easier
to get these kind of results because we
know exactly what our training
distribution is and we know our training
our test distribution is also similar to
that so I think it was convincing that
this was a this was a good result but
there needed to be lots of work done to
actually make sure this would work
generally great so this was the 1999
report turns out it underestimated the
severity of the problem more recent
analysis has calculated that a mean rate
of death from medical error is up to two
hundred and fifty-one thousand patients
per year which puts depth from medical
error as the third leading cause of
death in the United States after cancer
and heart disease
in terms of diagnostic error turns out
yes because you're including people
giving the wrong medication you're
including people dropping patients from
their movie new from one device to
another you're including people
operating on the wrong patient the types
of medical errors go way way beyond
anything that you could address yes you
absolutely may be somebody else yeah no
that's a fair point
so just to just to repeat your point the
sources of medical error are large it
just doesn't just come from diagnostic
interpretation errors it can be from
communication of the error between
between sorry communication
miscommunication between specialists and
between primary care physicians it can
come from the wrong medication it can
come from not not following not adhering
to the medication there's a large large
variety of things that are going on here
it's a complicated system yeah sure
perfect great one of the big sources of
medical errors are diagnostic errors and
there's been research spanning decades
here and looking at a variety of
different things there's post-mortem
examinations there's review of the
medical records that show that
diagnostic errors do contribute to a
large percentage a non-trivial
percentage of patient deaths
specifically looking at radiological
interpretation this is one study that
was done at the MGH where there were
readings performed by experienced
abdominal radiologists of exams they had
they or their colleagues had read
earlier and
the finding was that their disagreement
with others with their colleagues was
more than 30 percent of the time and
with themselves was about 25 percent of
the time
here's an example an actual example of a
case in which a misread x-ray of a
patient that had pneumonia led to
respiratory failure and death and just
to summarize the patient goes to the
express care clinic has a chest x-ray
taken it's interpreted as negative
realizes later that the x-ray is read
and excuse me realized it was later
realized that the patient had pneumonia
which was manifesting in their chest
x-ray and the clinic calls the patient
but by the time they get to the IDI the
patient has died of respiratory failure
associated with the pneumonia she's
talking about pneumonia one of the
things that we've done in the lab and
I'm working towards is being able to
automatically interpret chest x-rays and
make radiograph diagnosis using deep
learning so chest radiograph
interpretation is critical for the
detection and management of acute
thoracic diseases including pneumonia
and lung cancer which affect a lot of
people and this time-consuming task
requires expert radiologists to be able
to read the images and make the
interpretations and this is a big
problem in parts of the world where
access to radiology and radiologists is
limited the chest x-ray examination is
one of the most common examinations done
and includes having two views of a
patient from the back and from the side
to get an insight into what's going on
inside the lungs and the way
radiologists go about interpreting these
images is looking at abnormalities which
present mostly as areas of increased
density also called opacity here's an
example of one of the pathologies which
is pneumonia which most commonly
manifests as consolidation
which in layman's terms is a fluffy
cloud that one can see on the chest
x-ray and pneumonia occurs when the
alveoli the air sacs fill up with pus
but the alveoli can also fill up with
cells or with blood or with fluid in
which case that's a cancer or hemorrhage
or an edema and these can mimic the
appearance of pneumonia on these chest
x-rays so here we take a chest x-ray and
we're going to build a model which can
output the probability of a bunch of
different pathologies and have a
convolutional neural network this time
it's going to be 2d over these images
and the model is going to be pre trained
on imagenet and we're going to use
advancement architecture so earlier we
talked about short cut connections short
connections help with optimization and
that's what the residual networks work
found the dense network took that to an
extreme and said okay we know shortcut
works instead of adding shortcuts
between these particular set of layers
what if we added short cuts from every
layer to every other layer before it
taking that idea to the extreme and
turns out for the same number of
parameters dense Nets are able to
achieve a lower validation error than
their corresponding resonance when we
started work on this problem the NIH
released a large data set of chest
x-rays consisting of hundred thousand
images from 30 thousand patients which
was the largest public data set at the
time of release each of these x-rays was
annotated for the presence or absence of
14 different thoracic pathologies using
natural language processing on the
radiology reports and then a validation
set of 420 frontal view chest
radiographs was selected for
radiologists annotation where the
majority vote this time of three
cardiothoracic specialists serves as the
consensus reference standard for each
image to evaluate human performance this
time we have six radiologists
individually annotate the test set
now we note in this case there's no
access to patient history or prior
examinations which is important for a
lot of these interpretations and we only
have frontal radiographs no lateral
views so this is not a completely this
is not a this is not a comparison which
mimics clinical practice but it's an
approximation of of that so when we look
at how well the model does how well the
radiologists do the same setup of having
sensitivity plotted against one - its
specificity but the axis goes from one
to zero so being on the top left corner
is again ideal and the the algorithm is
the Purple Line and the Green Line is
generated by spline averaging the the
individual radiologists we can see here
that on a lot of pathologies that the
model does as well as the radiologists
are doing putting it on a table we found
no statistical difference on ten out of
these 14 pathologies on one pathology
atelectasis which which is a partial or
complete collapse of lung and is often
sort of a poor post surgical thing to
evaluate the algorithm did better and on
other pathologies like emphysema or
hernia the radiologists still perform
significantly better one of the
questions that comes up not just in this
particular case of Ches x-ray
interpretation but more generally in
medical imaging interpretation or in the
use of AI models for these tasks is how
can we trust the model how can we trust
that it's making decisions for the right
reasons one of the ways people have been
approaching this problem is by
generating heat maps over the image that
show where the algorithm is looking to
make its decision and one method for
that is the use of class activation maps
here's what class activation Maps
generated from the algorithm on these
chess x-rays look like so on the top is
an image of a chest x-ray with lung
cancer with two masses in in either lung
and we can see that the algorithm is
able to highlight those as it's making
its decision at the bottom is a
pneumonia that the algorithm is able to
catch accurately so the goal here is to
be able to improve healthcare delivery
help radiologists prioritize workflow
reduce diagnostic errors and to increase
access to medical imaging expertise
globally or right now 2/3 of the global
population estimated by the w-h-o lack
access to radiology Diagnostics yes
that's right so a good point is where
we're talking about increasing access to
radiology globally yet our data set is
from is from the US and that's very much
something that that we're working on
making generalizable from the data sets
that we work with to the data sets that
are out there and one important research
question is how well does the
generalization happen from data sets
here to data sets worldwide so what I
thought I'd show right now is a demo of
this particular use case and you know
when when people do chest x-ray
interpretation in many parts of the
developing world it's often done on
films it is not done with a digital
workflow the question is can we imagine
can we build towards a world in which I
can take a picture of an x-ray with my
phone give it to the algorithm that's
uploaded to the cloud and
and generate a diagnosis right from
there and so I'm going to demo you the
app right now okay so that's my phone
and what I'm going to do is pull up a
chest x-ray here so I already know the
label for this one so this is an
enlarged heart and just make it bigger
and on the left you can see my phone
screen so let's just make that clear
okay cool so I'm going to position it so
that the x-ray is is here and I'm gonna
make sure I don't get too much glare and
I capture all of it good okay so this is
my chest x-ray and you can see the
corners are a little cut off by the way
this is a chest x-ray that I got from
just googling this particular pathology
not at all in the training set I don't
know if it comes from the it from
America I don't know if it comes from
another place in the world and what
we're going to do here is that's alright
okay and so we're going to take this
picture and we're going to upload it and
it's running through the model right now
and within a few seconds it's come out
with its interpretation so on top here
is megali which refers to the enlarged
heart and you can see a little thing on
the corner there saying very likely so
its interpretation is is correct in this
case if we scroll down here's another
pathology says it's unlikely another one
that's unlikely here a few that are very
unlikely great and the idea is that we
are working towards making this
accessible such that one doesn't need to
have a digital radiology workflow to be
able to use algorithms like this but
instead it's with a snap of the phone
the third opportunity
that AI has in improving diagnosis is to
assist in medical decision making and
here throughout the diagnostic process
there's an opportunity to support
clinicians and patients to be able to
improve this experience let's talk about
clinical decision support tools so
clinical decision support tools have
been used in a variety of different
places within healthcare one of them is
radiology where the promises band of
computer-aided detection and one of the
use cases of that being screening for
mammography but despite this acceptance
that CAD will make a difference there's
been mixed evidence demonstrating its
effectiveness and challenges are that
for the use and acceptance of these
diagnostic decision support tools in
clinical practice they need to be used
only when it appropriate they need to be
understandable interpretable and enable
clinicians to quickly determine the
level of urgency or relevancy and of
course there's the potential patient
safety risk of that a clinician could be
over a lion on the decision support tool
that would in a way that would reduce
their independent clinical judgment and
critical thinking and there was one
study that found that clinicians can
override their own correct decisions in
this case and 6% of the cases due to
erroneous advice from the decision
support system so in the lab we took a
stab at this question to try to
understand okay we're developing some of
these AI models people are developing
lots of these AI models how can they
assist interpretation made by
radiologists here we looked at knee MRI
so MRF the knee is the standard care
modality to evaluate knee disorders and
more musculoskeletal m are examined
have performed on the knee than any
other part of the body and we ask the
questions first can we identify any
abnormalities at the level of
radiologists focusing on detecting
abnormalities and also the two most
common normality specifically which are
the ACL tear and the meniscal tear and
the setup of if we showed radiologists
the output of the model just one number
the probability of whether the algorithm
thought there was a ACL tear a meniscal
tear or an abnormality in this
particular image would they be able to
make better diagnosis so just a little
bit of a setup into what goes into a
model so when going from 2d to 3d
everything sort of expands so rather
than having one image now we have three
sets of images which are the different
ways of looking into the 3d anatomy of
the knee
which is the sagittal coronal and axial
series and then for each of them we have
using each of them we output a
probability of abnormal of ACL and a
miniscule tear and note that these don't
sum up to a hundred because they can all
co-occur this is a multi-label not a
multitask problem and we're going to
train nine convolutional neural networks
this time for each view and within each
view for each pathology and we're going
to combine them with the use of logistic
regression the idea here is to put each
image within a series through the same
set of layers to extract features and
then combine them through the max
pooling operation to generate an output
probability so we trained on a thousand
three hundred knee Ammar exams from
Stanford and we validated on one hundred
and twenty where the majority vote of
this time three musculoskeletal
radiologists established the reference
standard and we found that in terms of
performance
the model did really well but that
wasn't what we started out with we
started out with the question of how
well would radiologists now do at this
so one one thing is are we looking at
the right thing to be able to make the
diagnosis we looked at interpretation
earlier and here we can see the model
highlighting the part of the image where
it thinks there's an abnormality and if
you were to ask radiologists to make
this interpretation they would say that
it's it's able to localize correctly
here's another example where it wasn't
trained to identify these particular
normalities but in this case is able to
anyways a note on the external
validations one of the points that was
brought up earlier was we know that
these models yes
[Music]
whatever great yeah so I'll repeat the
question so why use a several 2d models
rather than have a 3d model that's able
to incorporate all of them so that's
great point and use of a 3d model we'll
be able to get information along the Z
dimension as well in a way that 2d model
just aren't able to capture the reason
we went for 2d models in this case is
twofold one is that it's straightforward
to use pre trained models when they're
in 2d and the second one is them is that
it takes up less memory this was also
the TAS in which we realized if we
started with the 2d approach and saw
that it didn't work that well we could
always move on to designing a more
complicated 3d approach but it was
interesting enough to test the
hypothesis of does the z axis actually
matter right now or can we make these
predictions independently on each frame
and combine them one of the points that
we touched on earlier was the need for
these models to generalize beyond the
population that they were trained on
this was trained on Stanford how well
would it do if I took examples in this
case from Croatia on patients who were
scanned from a different scanner with a
different protocol at a different
Hospital it turns out that just applying
the model without any tuning was able to
achieve a AUC of 0.8 to 4 which is which
is which is relatively good the best
publish results on this particular data
set had been point eight nine four so we
got close and even that one uses semi
automated approach so there was some
need for radiologists to do some
segmentation before that model started
working when we fine-tuned our model on
this particular data set we were
actually able to outperform the previous
best approach
so there is some gap that's needed to be
bridged to be able to apply these models
to different institutions and different
countries but it seems like we're some
of the way there and hopefully we can we
can go further with even more newer
techniques the real question we started
this project with was what radiologists
actually do better with AI and the way
we've set up this experiment was we had
experts read the same cases twice once
with the model help and once without the
model help but with a 10-day gap at
least in between and when we saw the
performance across the three tasks and
on specificity sensitivity and accuracy
we found that in terms of in terms of
performance assistance helped increase
the specificity for ACL tears so what
this would mean was if there were
hundred patients who did not have an ACL
tear we would send five fewer people to
surgery the utility of this is to help
reduce unnecessary testing and surgery
and give quick preliminary feedback for
patients whose exams come back as normal
so did I diagnostic future with AI is
hopeful there are many ways in which a I
can change the experience of the
diagnostic process for patients and for
doctors and there's a lot of work to be
done there to make this transformation
happen the work that I talked about
today has been made possible by a lot of
collaborators both in the med school and
then Stanford Mission Learning Group and
of course I'm thankful for for my lab
and professor and ruing for for making
that possible thank you for having me
here
you
[Applause]